- So how have you been keeping up.
So you have "This Is Us," do you all have,
I know that you get in these casts,
especially these really successful,
and y'all are on there for seasons,
have you all been able to catch up at all?
Have you all zoomed at
all or done anything?
- Yeah, so we have done the
Zoom, we have Zoom zoomed.
And it was so sweet because
Justin Hartley, who plays Kevin,
he's the one that's like,
"Hey, guys, do you wanna Zoom?"
And we're like, "Oh!"
(Kelly laughs)
And that's just Justin,
he's not just a handsome guy
who's super talented.
He has the biggest heart,
and so it was so cute
that he was the one that
wanted to arrange it.
And then Chris arranged
the actual appointment time
and called it the Miguel Rivas Fan Club,
which Jon Huertas plays Miguel, who,
and everyone there was
like, "No one likes Miguel."
Jon is the best sport about it all
because everybody just
makes a joke about it.
But yeah, it's a lot of fun.
We just get to sort of see
each other, which is nice.
It's like the phone calls
aren't quite enough,
and the text chats aren't-
- No, the getting to see each other,
like any kind of Zoom,
or FaceTime, I agree.
I mean, god, can you imagine
what this would be like without it?
Without seeing people,
like just on a phone,
like in the kitchen with
the Roseanne phone line
that's like 10-feet long.
Yeah, that would kill me.
Yeah.
- Yeah, it wouldn't be
good, that's for sure.
So, grateful for technology.
- Yeah, no, me too.
So who of your "This Is Us" cast
seem to be having the
best time in quarantine,
like when you all talked,
who's living their best life?
- I think really me.
Honestly.
(Kelly laughs)
I have to be honest, I
really like being at home.
- Oh, you don't have kids right now,
so that's, oh, there you go, that's why.
You know what, I'm telling you
that you're having the best time.
(Chrissy laughs)
I don't know about everybody else,
but I love actually
getting to have the time,
especially recently, I've
been waking up every morning,
coloring with them, it's like a lot of
kind of me time with
them and I've loved that.
But at the same time,
it's like, "Oh my gosh,
I really want to go to
a dinner with adults
and just talk about adult things."
- Right.
I mean, I feel for Sterling
'cause he and Ryan,
he and his wife are obviously
teaching their two sons,
and he's like, (sighs)
"Man, I gotta run, guys.
I gotta start class.
We gotta do this, we gotta that."
- Oh my gosh.
- I know. I don't (sigh).
Listen, I can barely
keep a succulent alive
that I started having at
the beginning of quarantine.
- (laughs) Succulents are like
the easiest plants to keep alive.
- They don't need anything.
- I know, that's amazing.
That's why you're my favorite human.